[Música]
bienvenidos a ello soy de france24 hay
muchas formas de protesta y una de ellas
es la música a propósito de las
manifestaciones feministas del mes de
marzo por el día internacional de los
derechos de la mujer vamos a conversar
con dos feministas que impulsan encantos
contra el machismo con una voz potente
en panamá del fondo de población de las
naciones unidas- con apoyo del sector
privado creó un proyecto llamado letras
contra la violencia de ahí nació
desaparecidas en honor de las mujeres de
panamá y de chile
y miedo
hijos
[Música]
amiga
ya pasó un año y no he vuelto a ver
cómo es que a mi bebé no la encuentran
[Música]
mire
qué cosas
mónica y no volvería a hacer bien
[Música]
sí
conmigo a todos lados dios si la tabla
si no tiene buena también
sí
y no vota sino canasteras tu madre
con estilismos asesinos
[Música]
le doy la bienvenida a miroslaw a
herrera vocalista del grupo afrodisíaco
y activista panameña por los derechos
humanos de la mujer bienvenida y una de
las protagonistas de la iniciativa
desaparecidas es usted que puso su voz
para hacer activismo desde la música
esta es una canción modificada de rubén
blades cuéntenos esa historia porque
eligieron esa letra para empezar y en
qué consisten los cambios
muchas gracias este proyecto nació como
una colaboración con colegas de chile de
comprar y station project con pollo de
ibermúsica decidimos hacer busco este
musical e intercambiar canciones así las
colegas y escogían una canción para
meliá para solemnizar y nosotras desde
panamá íbamos a para amenizar una
canción chilena y las cóleras es decir
escogieron desaparecida esta canción del
maestro rubén blades para hablar de algo
que nos afecta para hablar de esta cosa
que que es como un fuego en todo el
continente es la violencia de género
violencia de todo tipo que destruyen
nuestras comunidades entonces que
hicimos que el proyecto tuviese ese
puente porque con chile panamá chile
comparten muchas clases comerciales
históricos pero también compartimos esta
situación entonces que hicimos quedará
el proyecto estuviese lleno de realidad
así que así nació la modificación de
desaparecidas tuvimos la aprobación del
maestro rubén blades para intervenir tu
canción y poder traer esta canción que
habla de víctimas de violencia política
de los años 80 a víctimas de violencia
de género en nuestros países en nuestras
casas nuestras comunidades así que esta
es nuestro nuestro grito de justicia
como artistas nos quedan pocos minutos
para seguir conversando pero quisiera
que no se nos quedará por fuera el tema
de resignificar la música hábleme de esa
conquista de los espacios que
tradicionalmente maltratan a la mujer
que no tienen en cuenta una visión de
género pero que en este proyecto se
pusieron a favor de los derechos humanos
cantar por el bien de todas y de todos
al final
nosotros creemos que el arte tiene el
poder para modificar la cultura de
destruir estos patrimonios tóxicos y de
generar empatía y eso es el tipo de
artistas que queremos hacer despertar
esa conciencia que puede mejorar la
cultura y cambiarla para bien
hay un tema hay un tema miroslava y es
la representación de la mujer y la estoy
viendo personificada en usted misma no
solamente de las mujeres del mundo sino
de las mujeres afro latinas que son
doblemente victimizadas y que son
puestas en peligro por una sociedad
patriarcal usted es la representación de
esto
si nuestra plataforma es usar los
tambores afro panameños para visibilizar
todo este potencial y también para
visibilizar las reparaciones pendientes
porque el cabello aforo aunque es un
aspecto estético también ha significado
la victimización y la vergüenza y de
hecho la vergüenza crea pobreza en
nuestra en las mujeres afro en toda
américa latina porque si puedes
convencer a una persona de que es
inapropiada entonces puedes excluir la y
puedes ajustar de ella y eso es una cosa
que caracteriza a nuestra música de
empoderar a través de poder visibilizar
dónde están las trampas y dónde están
los obstáculos para la sociedad a la que
esperamos tener gracias miroslava y yo a
usted la veo hermosa con su melena
vamos a escuchar ahora una segunda
composición la canción es sin miedo de
la mexicana vivir quintana y el palomar
se lanzó en el 2020 y desde entonces se
ha convertido en un himno feminista que
ha sido adaptado en varios países según
sus propias historias
[Música]
tiembla el estado en los cielos las
calles
[Música]
ayala
calma no sé
[Música]
crecieron nada
minutos cada semana
[Música]
mientras está en sus cuerpos los
desaparecen
es verdad
señor presidente
por todas las cosas
[Música]
sí
pedimos justicia gritamos por cada vez
el feminicida
yo todo lo incendio yo todos los rombos
y un día algo un fulano te apaga los
ojos ya no
ya todo me sobra si tocan a una
tenemos todas
[Música]
la niña que subiste
si la madre
[Música]
vivir quintana es una cantautora
mexicana y una activista por los
derechos de las mujeres gracias por su
tiempo y comienzo preguntándole de una
vez su canción no es nueva pero si se
renueva constantemente con las
adaptaciones que han hecho mujeres de la
región para denunciar los crímenes en
los países usted que piensa cada vez que
nace otra versión de su trabajo o la
angela pues primero muchas gracias por
el espacio y creo que es súper
lamentable que cada vez haya más
versiones de la canción el año pasado
que sacamos este tema que fue en 2020 el
7 de marzo con el marco del 8 m
dijimos todas las compañeras ojalá que
esta canción sea la única vez que se
cante y que no volvamos a tener que
cantarla sin embargo creo que la
violencia está vigente siempre está todo
el tiempo vigente las 24 horas los de
todos los días de la semana entonces por
eso se sigue cantando la canción este 8
de marzo me han llegado versiones de
todas partes del mundo y es lamentable
porque esto quiere decir que a las
mujeres nos hermana y nos atraviesa el
dolor
qué es el feminicidio este problema de
salud tan fuerte que tenemos no nada más
en méxico sino en todo el mundo usted
tiene casi 20.000 comentarios en su
vídeo de youtube de la canción sin miedo
muchísimos son testimonios de violencia
y de desaparición su canción ha
encontrado el camino para mantener las
historias de las mujeres vivas que de
otra manera pasarían a ser parte de las
estadísticas que son tantas en el mundo
y especialmente en américa latina'
qué opina de eso
pues a mí me parece algo fíjate que con
esta canción es algo de doble mente con
con sentimientos encontrados porque por
un lado siento esa alegría de estar como
acompañando a tantas compañeras pero
también la desfortuna de leer tantos
testimonios porque creo que ya en la
plataforma donde está la canción que es
en youtube ya está llena es un muro de
denuncia es un muro de de todos estos
testimonios entonces quiere decir que
cada vez están saliendo a flote todas
las esos silencios que hemos callado
todos esos silencios de historias que
han sucedido y que lamentablemente
siguen sin darse la solución entonces
creo que el arte y por ejemplo la música
la música siempre acompañado los grandes
las grandes luchas las grandes
revoluciones entonces esta lucha
feminista esta revolución de nosotros
las mujeres pues no podía quedarse atrás
sin música entonces pues la música nos
ha ayudado a levantar la voz a sacar la
voz y sobre todo estar presentes en este
movimiento y en estos cambios que son
tan necesarios
a nuestro país y para latinoamérica y
hacer catarsis y a reconocer que lo que
nos está pasando es gravísimo ustedes
diría que que esta es una forma de
protesta pacífica porque yo escucho una
letra llena de indignación y llena de
ira y eso no está mal en este mes de las
marchas de las mujeres hay muchas
críticas porque rompen paredes porque
queman las cosas pero es que los
derechos no se piden por favor claro y
yo siempre he dicho que yo no le puedo
pedir a una compañera oa una madre que
ha perdido a su hija y que se le han
devuelto destazada en una maleta de
cinco años a una niña que la han
secuestrado y que la han hecho de todo
yo no le puedo pedir a esas mujeres que
pidan las cosas por favor que digan que
esperen afuera de un palacio nacional a
que alguien salga y les dé resolución a
su problema y que les dé una una
justicia que es lo que tanto se busca
entonces eso no se puede pedir entonces
nada más hay que respetar tratar de
ponernos empáticamente en el lado de
esas mujeres en el lado de esas personas
que es donde se busca esta justicia y ya
dimos cuenta que la violencia ha sido
sistematizada por mucho tiempo entonces
hay que entenderlo tratar de entenderlo
tal vez para muchos cuando lo vemos de
otro punto o de afuera no lo entendemos
pero hay que tratar de comprenderlo
porque el dolor realmente nos está
atravesando a todo méxico a toda
latinoamérica y ahora todo el mundo no
entonces que haya versiones de canción
sin miedo en alemán que haya canciones
en francés que haya canciones en
italiano esto quiere decir que nos
atraviesa todas este dolor muchas
gracias muchas gracias a ustedes y
muchas gracias también a miroslaw a
herrera desde panamá dos visiones que se
acercan mucho nos faltan muchas no
estamos completas y que se note la
indignación siga con nosotros en france
[Música]